foreign
I remember learning my colors
started by learning about the primary
colors red yellow and blue
our teacher taught us how they were the
pure colors of the rainbow no two colors
could be combined to create them
our next task was to mix them into
something more complex green purple and
orange
these secondary colors especially green
stood out to me I was fascinated by how
two primary colors could be mixed
together to create something nuanced and
completely unique
when our teacher told us that our next
task was to draw a picture of our family
I couldn't wait
I started by drawing my stick figure mom
dad and brother but then filled in the
white space with something else
I'd use the washable paints I'd mixed
just a few minutes ago to create the
colors of my family
I colored my mom yellow my dad blew and
my brother and I green
every time someone asks about my
background I'm reminded of that art
class my mom is 100 Ashkenazi Russian
Jewish and my dad is 50 Korean and 50
Belgian
so what does that make me
how should I describe myself
where do I fit in among the color
spectrum we were all taught in first
grade
by definition race is a categorization
of humans based on physical and social
qualities
the term is first used to refer to
speakers of a Common Language or to
denote National affiliation
but by the 17th century the term
referred to physical traits
so am I white or am I Asian
the question of race has followed me
around for as long as I can remember
ever since I started taking standardized
tests or filling out online surveys I've
been asked to select my race
and every time I take a pause to think
about which box I should choose
I'm white and Asian but I'm not allowed
to click both so which do I pick
well when I was younger I would always
choose White I simply concealed the
portion of my identity to make my life
easier
instead of having to think about what
other meant on those surveys I would
compress my identity into one single box
it was quick and easy fix
but as I got older I realized that other
better reflected my multiracial
background
but that choice of other comes at a cost
even though I'm surrounded by loving and
understanding people every time I go to
check that box I'm forced to think of
myself as other or someone who doesn't
exactly fit in like I'm some sort of
anomaly or evidence of something strange
I don't want the world to see me as
other or the given boxes on those
surveys I know there's so much more to
me but clearly Society doesn't see it
that way
they want a simplified view of who each
of us are
but these days are any of us that simple
one of my best friend says it perfectly
people are like an entire rainbow and
shouldn't be defined by just one of
their colors
the one box rule from test service has
confused multiracial people since the
beginning of the U.S census for the
longest time in America you could only
select one box from being asked about
your race
the Census Bureau didn't start to allow
choosing more than one box until the
year 2000. 2 000 that was only 22 years
ago
every multiracial person living in
America before the year 2000 had to at
some point fill out a form stating that
they identify as One Singular race
white black Asian indigenous Pacific
Islander for everyone in that situation
you probably chose one of those reducing
your racial makeup into one box
or you chose other like me because
you're an aware secondary color of the
rainbow
so what does other mean
the definition is literally someone who
is different than one already known
about
these people who choose other aren't
different like we're comparing apples to
oranges
ten percent of the American population
is multiracial which measures out to
about 33.8 million people
within that number there are so many
combinations of cultures and races yet
we're all forced to fit into one box
not only is a multi-racial person's
experience different from those who are
of One race but that experience also
varies from person to person
there's a wide spectrum forced to be
contained into one small square an
effect that minimizes the racial
experience
look what just happened the same color
but five different ways
categorizing all multiracial people as
other is just like saying that Navy and
Periwinkle are the same shade of blue
and that number in America is rapidly
growing each year in the last 10 years
there's a 276 percent increase of
multiracial identifying individuals at
some point in the future there will be
more people choosing other than the
handful of given boxes on those surveys
though this ever expanding rainbow is a
beautiful thing having all of those
people have to categorize themselves as
other in society is not
that's why I introduce a new idea of
racial categorization in the form of an
open-ended question
it would recognize a spectrum that's
lacking in our world today
one study done by scientist Alicia Tran
and others showed that an open-ended
question provided an experience once
deprived when being asked about race
with only a few options
an open-ended question would give people
an opportunity to express pride in their
multiracial backgrounds
as our world continues to racially
intertwine we will reach a point where
it will become impossible to categorize
people by a handful of outdated and
predetermined boxes
even now we're seeing a declining
population of Reds yellows and blues and
an increasing community of oranges
purples and greens
as such we can no longer expect people
to Define who they are by simply
checking a primary color
although race is a social construct
built on a structure of assumptions and
stereotypes we cannot simply get rid of
race altogether
however the Simplicity and ease of an
open-ended question could truly lead our
society into a more inclusive and
accepting world that acknowledges the
spectrum of racial identities
a world where all the Shades of Greens
purples and oranges are just as
recognized as the Reds yellows and blues
thank you
foreign